tales of guys my name is Jenna and
welcome back to episode 120 of game
programming so last time we created the
exited and entered events and set up a
few different things for our buttons and
this time we're going to be taking a
little press and release and basically
making this action listener actually do
something so whilst we can detect
whether or not the mouse is inside the
button or not which is very nice we also
want to be able to obviously press the
button and we want it to be able to do
something that's the whole point of
having buttons so to do that we
basically need to call these pressed and
released events that we made okay then
all the events it's just that yeah
they're just actions kind of that we can
override but the idea is what we need to
do is in update this is going to be
relatively straightforward and simple
once we check to make sure that it's
inside and one make sure it's inside the
if statement obviously we need to handle
press and released inside here so what
we want to do is basically just check to
see if the mouse is pressed right so if
mouse dot get button equals mouse dot
what even is that it's like Mouse events
dot button one I think I think one would
be left button I'm not even sure but if
that's the case let's just actually make
sure that this is correct I'll just type
in I was to print call okay it seems to
be right so if this is the case we need
to do we need to do a few things first
of all if this is the first time that
that's kind of happened then we want to
print we want to basically register a
press event okay but once we release it
we want to register a release event so
this is a bit more complicated because
it needs to work well right so if we
just have a private boolean pressed
equals false as well what you could do
is you could set pressed equal to true
okay you could also call what is it the
button listener
yeah button listener dot pressed so
we'll call that set press true and maybe
just only do this if pressed is false
okay so you could do something like this
and then I guess if if you release it
so if else if this is not pressed so I'd
I don't know equals zero right so I
guess zero I'm not sure but what is
button one actually but one one I guess
a no button there is no button no button
then whoops my mouse event dot no button
then we will set press equal to false
one thing that actually doesn't need to
happen is almost the reverse so inside
is false so what happens is pressed
equals true this actually has to be yes
false actually no it's correct hang on
is it yes if not prior yep okay that is
correct
I'm I keep doubting myself and I really
shouldn't but you know sometimes I I do
that okay so this sounds pretty good and
we can obviously call released here and
I'm actually curious to see if this
works out correctly because I don't see
it happening that's me again with a
doubt let's just print out pressed and
released make sure you put an
exclamation mark nice just so much more
exciting all right let's see so pressed
released so release didn't run yeah I
expected it not sure so yeah it it has
let's just get rid of that that would be
why because of the pressed thing maybe
not so if it equals no button so this is
more or less if pressed is actually true
and we're at no button so you could call
this an else but this should only happen
if pressed is actually true okay now
unfortunately I'm not 100% convinced
that get button returns what we want
because we didn't set up our mouse to
have release events unfortunately so one
negative one now that's because we set
it to that so this is bad
we shouldn't have done this this is
actually a bad mouse code what we should
have done is actually said Mouse event
dog no button because I assumed the
button I don't know why but I must have
thought that that no button was negative
one whereas it's one so I must have
thought the left mouse button was with
zero but it was actually one because you
can see no button is zero so there's
just there's no such thing as negative
one really it's not here so no button is
what we're actually used for sorry no
button is actually what we're looking
for so back in UI button we yeah as you
can see that did work so if we go back
here pressed released press release now
if we press it here and exit okay the
question is do we release it because you
can see that no event runs until we
actually release it so if exited happens
you know do we actually release it
that's the question so we could do
something like that okay so for example
you can see and this kind of boils down
to how you think button what buttons
work how they should work and all that
stuff so if we like the close button for
example if we press that and then move
away you can see that it releases it
completely okay but if we move back it's
still pressed yeah so that
that's some pretty that's pretty basic
behavior and that's usually how you want
your buttons to probably work okay so in
this case all we need to do is we need
to say that if we're inside and we've
left the bounds apart from just exiting
we need to check if we check to see if
we're pressed and if so we run the
actually I don't even need to do that
hang on because that actually does call
it oh I think this works perfectly hang
on
funds are confusing give me a minute I
think what we need to do is let's do
something different
when we press so when we release we'll
set whatever you need to do that I don't
think when we press let's set the color
to something yeah I don't think this
will work actually let's set the color
to I guess it needs to be a bit darker
doesn't know I don't know well let's set
it to like let's set it to red or
something I don't know I'm out of ideas
so we press that it goes red and then
you can see if we go back it's just
completely kind of dead okay
unlike unlike with this close button
where if we press it it changes color we
move it away we go back and it's still
that same color okay
so what's happened there is it's kind of
said hey if you exit and the button is
pressed
I'm not going to register any events
until you release the mouse button so
that's something again that's like a
whole other kind of discipline almost I
want to say of how you actually want to
solve that so I don't know if that's
really required for us because that's
probably let's check out logic real
quick
so we do that stuff
so we exit we enter a little press again
yeah so okay so what we need to do is
this will make a private bullying called
I'm not sure what we should call this
will call this will call is blocked or
something is that it equal to false so
this is what happens when we press we
set blocked equal to true right and when
we release because because this is the
important part right
if blocked is true we need to change
that name because it's really horrific
but if it is blocked we'll sets will
actually perform our action so we'll do
it on release okay so if our action was
set to something like or what have we
set it to so we can test our now cuz
it's a button press right let's get rid
of I'll leave that in there so when we
press it and release it you can see that
we get the button pressed okay if we go
back and release it we also get the
button breast but what we don't get is
that back to kind of stage so what we do
want to do is we want to kind of call we
want to we want to almost call pressed
again so whenever we do that without the
block thing in fact it's just that we
don't want to I'm not sure the release
does actually get called twice
we'll see ourselves with another problem
region
huh that's weird all right oh I see hope
so much
so much confusing functionality so this
press in released only should happen if
we actually press the button inside the
bounds of the button as well so yeah fun
stuff buttons let's set the color yeah
okay that's fine
so blocked equals true yeah look no it
illegal false what what is this oh my
goodness something's wrong okay we're
back
I don't know what that was nothing that
was just camped ahead you're freaking
out
yeah so I'm not sure what we should do
here I think so that's just okay so
write down the terms for it yeah you
know it's like true
so if mouse button is one press is false
right
right so we said prostate yeah we don't
need this block thing okay I think we're
actually good
they're nice block thing miles
overthinking that but that's all good so
if we release the mouse button
there it'll be fine
it's just that something that's just
okay let's do something like this I
think instead of button press we'll do
something like systems I'll exit just so
we can clearly see when that gets cold
so if I press that release it somewhere
else and then yeah that's the problem I
was worried about so when we exit we're
just going to do this actually this
probably makes a bit more sense as well
if we exit we're going to set pressed
equal to false this is if we're inside
yeah I think so
is that even all right okay so we can
press the button we can go away and it
won't actually close the game but if we
press it like that it will okay cool -
brilliant
there's our functionality all
implemented let's go back here real
quick and get rid of this so we'll
probably say these colors up properly
instead of hard-coding them and whatnot
but what we yeah
there we go all good in the hood now so
you can see if we take it out and then
back in and whatnot it stays red just
like this would stay like this would
stay kind of pale red and if we let go
it'll close up so same here yeah and
then close it cool so we've got a fully
functional button now I works much like
the windows API which is good probably
the only thing we can do that's a bit
weird is click somewhere else drag in
and it will actually register as pressed
so that's we can release it which is
also a bit weird because we should get
it so the click actually originates in
here ok so that's going to be a bit fun
ok but we've got that and also the color
stuff so I'm going to leave that till
next time just we're out of time but
yeah so we'll cover some more advanced
button stuff next time and also instead
of having these colors hard-coded here
we'll actually set them up because one
thing you can do right now is actually
customize your own UI button listener
and we'll add that as probably but let's
just quickly check that in now so we'll
just say public void set set button
listener will take in a UI button
listener
then we'll just apply that and that way
you can override these because this is
like the default behavior you can
override them and set them to whatever
you like so yeah anyway hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of game programming
if you did please hit like button and I
will see you guys next time goodbye
you